let's face it with the economy still in  a little bit of a rough spot most people  are on a tight budget so here with some  money saving Thanksgiving tips is our  prop master bill tall bill  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  pick a black wastebasket put a bells on  it boom pilgrim ass  here's bill with another tip take a golf  shoe pour gravy in it boom gravy boat  here's another one take a loaf of bread  put it in a paper shredder boom  stuffing take a Nicolas Cage movie boom  turkey take a pumpkin divide its  circumference by its diameter boom  pumpkin pie  [Applause]  have dinner with your wife invited her  to join you  boom side dish  [Applause]  take a stick of butter put it down your  pants  boom butterball  [Applause]  take your coat your car keys walk out  the door without telling your family  where you're going boom Happy  Thanksgiving  [Applause]  you